who do you think is the best hire so far
i you know i really like for his team at
this time i really like mike mccarthy
um just because i think that
that
there needed to be in dallas a the buck
stops here
guy and mike mccarthy is going to be
that guy jerry jones feels comfortable
with mccarthy that he's going to be able
to get more out of his team we'll see if
he does than jason garrett got out of
him and i also think
that he's looking forward to
sort of sharpening up the mechanics
um of of his quarterback i think
that dak prescott is a very good player
right now but i think there were two
quarterbacks
in this derby right now that mike
mccarthy was really interested in
working with one was dak prescott and
one was daniel jones and i think if he
could have gotten one of those two jobs
he was gonna be very happy
i think that the fact that he's gonna i
think sharpen up prescott a little bit
get him to be a little bit less
inconsistent because he he had some real
big peaks this year that lasted longer
than any year in his career but he also
had some valleys as well and i think
they'll work on that and the one other
thing about mccarthy
he's got to stick to what he did in the
offseason which is to be
to be willing to
to look at analytics more and to be a
lot more imaginative uh than he was late
in his green bay career i think if he
does that then dallas has a winner
you know there's an angle that we were
spitballing about yesterday when sims
was on the show and i saw that rob
dymovsky of espn.com gave some credence
to this as a matter of fact that the
cowboys were convinced that the packers
teams that have beaten the cowboys teams
in recent years including twice in the
division around the playoffs that the
cowboys teams were better than the
packers teams from a talent standpoint
and mike mccarthy was able to overcome
with a less talented roster a cowboys
team that the joneses think should have
advanced in both of those games that's a
feather in mccarthy's cap as well when
it comes to getting that job but for me
i'm i'm a big fan of the ron rivera hire
in washington just because
the team and the organization
are too damn dysfunctional to hire ron
rivera to whatever they did to get ron
rivera bravo because i think ron rivera
comes in he will stabilize things he's
going to instill discipline
accountability he will have a calm even
demeanor in front of the cameras but
behind closed doors if you saw all or
nothing on amazon prime with the full
season they were with the carolina
panthers i mean you know get the
earmuffs out for the kids because ron
rivera will be fiery and feisty when he
has to be this is exactly what
washington needs and i if if we would
have taken these names the four names
and tried to do you know the puzzle
where you've got the four teams the four
names and you draw the lines peter i
would have drawn joe judge to washington
because it would have seemed like hey
they got the guy that nobody else even
wanted who's joe judge how's he getting
a job well he's getting a job in
washington because they can't convince
anyone else to come coach the team
yeah i think you know mike i think the
reason why you like ron rivera to
washington
uh as much as you do is because it comes
without bruce allen you know that
franchise now
as as big a higher as big an addition
as ron rivera was the subtraction of
bruce allen was just as important and i
like bruce allen he's a great historian
of the game uh i think he's a real
bright guy
but as a team architect team chemistry
maker and all that stuff i mean the guys
in the locker room hated the front
office just hated it they hated the
medical staff in a lot of ways and and
you know they needed to get rid of bruce
allen the most important thing in my
opinion that the owner did was to be
willing to clean out the front office
and medical staff that was crucial and
it allows ron rivera to come in with
truly a clean slate so that he can go
have lunch with trent williams in
houston at some point in the next month
and say big guy
i really want you back
and trent williams might very well come
back uh but that was the big
that i just think it was a bigger thing
than hiring ron rivera without any i'm
not getting down on ron revere at all
they needed to change
everything about this organization and
good for daniel snyder he hasn't done a
lot of good things in recent years but
this certainly was one of them
yeah i still wonder how much of a
surrogate bruce allen was for dan snyder
and as long as he owns the team there's
that possibility that the dysfunction
flows not from alan but from snyder and
can he contain it has he changed is it
still going to be there in some other
form they're going to hire a new gm
apparently after the draft so we'll
learn more about that as the offseason
unfolds but joe judge welcome to the nfc
east his stats texted me during this
segment the other three coaches not
named joe judge in the nfc east have all
been to or won a super bowl
so you're up against it joe judge you've
been there with the patriots but not as
a head coach and you know all of a
sudden the cachet of the nfc least has
been elevated by these hires it's going
to be an interesting season or two or
more for the nfc
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports